at the start of the movie an old woman
is seen crawling in her apartment
probably because her legs are too weak
to stand up then she ties a long rope to
the table and throws the other end out
of the window it appears as if she hates
the apartment so much that she is trying
to escape it one way or the other
despite her old age and fragile body she
somehow climbs outside and grabs the
Rope tightly but just when she prepares
to slide down her hands slip causing her
to fall it appears as if she has died
but when the camera pans to her it is
revealed that the Rope has miraculously
held on to her leg the old lady tries to
reach for the ground but the Rope pulls
her upstairs back into her apartment
then the Windows shut forever a few
months later a young 25 year old girl
named Anna arrives at the same apartment
to rent it where she is greeted by the
building manager Mueller and the current
tenant it seems as if the current tenant
is a different old lady than the one we
saw at the start Anna closely inspects
the room and finds it fascinating she
becomes even more enticed when Mueller
mentions the extremely low rent of the
apartments which is situated in central
Vienna before signing the rent agreement
Anna asks the old lady why she's moving
out to which the latter replies that she
wants to travel the world Anna finds it
very strange that a woman her age wants
to travel but nonetheless she believes
her it's not that strange people these
days don't retire until they're almost
dead after this she reveals that she is
new to the city and that she has come
with her ex-boyfriend however things
didn't quite work out for her and now
she is all alone as Anna continues
explaining her story The Old Woman
becomes anxious and asks her if she
wants the apartment or not Anna replies
yes and Mueller hands her the rent
agreement contract she tries signing it
but the pen doesn't work however the old
lady has a spare one in her hand this
indicates that she is in a hurry to hand
over the apartment to Anna and as soon
as the deal is done the lady takes her
belongings and leaves happily soon
Mueller also departs but not before
telling Anna to call him if she needs
any help following this Anna quickly
gets to cleaning and rearranging the
place she brings all her stuff in and
start painting the walls the place is
very dusty so Anna throws out all the
useless items including a small piece of
cloth that lies on top of a shelf but
when she returns back after dumping the
trash strangely the place has again
reverted back to its old self the new
painting has become dirty the furniture
is covered with dust and the fresh
fruits instantly have become rotten the
piece of cloth that was above the Shelf
has also returned Anna is stunned by the
strange occurrence but she doesn't care
much and refurbishes the place once
again Anna is insane however every time
she goes to throw the garbage bags the
apartment again becomes a mess and
because of the constant hard work Anna's
eyes start becoming wrinkly and dark
that night she sleeps on the couch tired
when the radio suddenly starts playing
Anna goes to turn it off but when she
sees her face in the mirror she realizes
that her face has changed drastically
the very next morning an enraged Anna
goes to the house manager Mueller and
berates him for offering her a haunted
apartment she also demands her security
deposit back but mean responds that it's
not possible he then brings out the rent
agreement contract and shows a clause
which states that a tenant may not leave
the apartment until and unless a new
tenant arrives the Clause is written in
such tiny words that a magnifying glass
is required to read it as expected Anna
bursts out in anger and threatens to
report him to the police but Mueller
doesn't seem to be phased he simply
warns her to stay in the apartment
because that is what the contract States
however Anna pays no heed to the warning
and the leaves she heads straight to a
clinic to obtain a medical report so
that she can file a complaint with the
police but strangely the doctor believes
that her wrinkly skin and gray hair is
normal for a 25 year old woman Anna
shouts in Anger that she has every right
to get tested and whips out her ID to
her horror the contents of her ID have
been wiped out shortly after she heads
to a hotel to stay for the night the
receptionist again asks for an ID and
Anna has to pay extra money for the room
that night Anna suddenly wakes up and
realizes that she has become weak lo and
behold it turns out that she has been
become extremely old like an 80 year old
woman Anna slowly walks to the sink and
coughs resulting in a couple of her
teeth falling out the following day she
heads back to the haunted apartment and
confronts Mueller the latter is not
surprised by her condition and simply
mentions that she should have followed
the protocols which clearly say don't
get out of the house here we get to know
that if a tenant signs the contract and
gets out of their Apartments they age
rapidly until they pass away Mueller
also reveals that the apartment doesn't
like to be alone and this is why a
tenant must always be there and you
thought clingy Partners were bad
following the conversation Anna Leaves
for her room and after a while Mueller
suddenly realizes that his box of
matchsticks is missing he rushes to
Anna's apartments and finds that the
door has been locked inside the old lady
is sprinkling whiskey all over the room
determined to burn it down however when
she lights a Matchstick the place
doesn't catch fire she attempts to try
again but unfortunately the house
becomes angry and starts choking her as
Anna drops to the floor gasping for air
Mueller somehow opens the door and tends
to her he removes a piece of cloth from
her mouth hence saving her life
strangely the cloth is the same one that
is always lying above the shelf shortly
after Mueller Hands Anna a drink and
starts talking about the apartment he
reveals that the apartment has been in
existence for over a decade and at all
times there has been a tenant inside in
one instance some schoolgirls lived
there but all of them became grannies in
a matter of days the incident made it to
the news and caused Nationwide unrest a
minister even attempted to destroy the
apartment to bring an end to the sorcery
however he was mysteriously found dead
before his plan commenced this implied
that the apartment didn't want any
external interference and so the
government stopped caring about it and
kept it a secret this is why even the
police don't take any actions against
the supposedly haunted Apartments now
Mueller has been assigned as the
caretaker of the place and it is his
duty to make sure that people visit it
regularly it is a job he doesn't like
but one that he has to do before leaving
Mueller suggests a shivering Anna find a
new tenant as that is the only way she
can escape the apartment that evening
the old woman puts on some makeup and
heads to her ex-boyfriend Daniel's place
for help unfortunately he doesn't even
recognize her and says that he's in a
hurry Anna tries to reveal her real
identity but Daniel assumes that she's
his ex-girlfriend's grandmother at the
same time his new girlfriend arrives in
her car to pick him up it turns out that
the two are also apartment hunting Anna
has the perfect opportunity to set them
up and trap them in the apartments but
she doesn't say a word and lets them
leave later at night while Anna is
sleeping the radio again starts playing
and some objects move by themselves it
turns out that the apartment is trying
to be friends by preparing a lovely meal
for her when Anna wakes up she finds
food right next to her couch but instead
of eating it she throws it away however
when she learns that the apartment has
also prepared some tea she decides to
try some Anna slowly pours the tea into
a cup and takes a sip surprisingly she
likes it prompting her to pick up a
biscuit from near the dust bin where she
had disposed of the food earlier Anna is
too fragile and weak to cook food and
now she has started relying on her only
friend the apartment over the course of
the next few days Anna becomes extremely
fragile and she requires a cane to walk
her body looks as if she is over a
hundred years old she stares at her
wrist and notices something moving
inside so she starts peeling off her
skin shockingly the skin comes off
without any effort revealing a strange
wire-like substance inside Anna knows
that her impending doom is near so she
calls Mueller over to her place in the
next scene a couple finally arrives at
the apartment to rent it out they are
revealed to be none other than Anna's
ex-boyfriend Daniel and his new
girlfriend as usual the two are enticed
by the cheap rent and good furniture
around the place they also like the fact
that no other tenants live in nearby
apartments which makes it extra peaceful
hence they agree to sign the contract
Mueller happily hands them over the rent
agreement and Daniel gets ready to put
pen to paper Anna who is watching
everything transpire from nearby
suddenly has a flashback of the time
where she was trapped in a similar way
she recalls the pain and misery she has
been through because of this doomed
apartment hence before her ex-boyfriend
can sign his death warrant she pours hot
tea into his hand and thwarts him away
Anna then screams at the young couple to
get out of her apartment and never come
back Daniel and his spouse are visibly
stunned by the old lady's actions but
they leave without saying a word with
this Anna loses her last chance to get
out of this apartment she could have
trapped her ex-boyfriend and lived the
last few days of her life in peace and
Tranquility but she chose not to this
shows that her love for Daniel still
exists and that she is ready to
sacrifice her life and end the cycle of
this wretched apartment even Mueller is
surprised by her selfishness and
resilience before he leaves Anna orders
him to lock the door from the other side
and not return for at least a few years
she hopes that if no one comes the cycle
will finally end and the spirit inside
the apartment will die Mueller obliges
and leaves the place after wishing her
good luck now Anna is all alone in the
apartment no one is coming to meet her
and she doesn't have the strength or
physique to venture downstairs she goes
near the window and feels the breeze one
last time which makes her feel relaxed
and calm all the fear and anxiety that
she faced over the last few weeks has
vanquished and Anna has finally accepted
her fate she softly asks the apartment
to be gentle and then proceeds to the
couch which will be her final resting
place soon the apartment commences the
procedure Anna instantly passes away and
her head is swallowed by the couch and
becomes a part of it slowly her body
also mixes inside the couch only her
clothes remain and from the old woman's
heart comes out pieces of wires that
automatically knit themselves into the
couch cushions her head turns into a
white cloth and right next to it are the
two identical white clothes indicating
that the apartment uses its victim to
renew itself however with no victims
left we can only assume the apartment
will soon die talk about reupholstery
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching